he's obsessed with you yeah I'm a
veterinarian so he knows you're a
veterinarian right don't you think
that's weird and cool because he has all
over you today you're a he trusts me he
knows yeah do you think that dogs really
can sense the goodness in someone or the
darkness absolutely they have an
intuitive sense that I don't think we
appreciate and so you know as a
veterinarian we read subtle cues about
what a dog is feeling and like the way
the eyes are the ears and so when you
when you see that you kind of can read
how they're feeling they also pick up on
cues for us as well they know who they
can trust if my dog likes you then
you're good